how are you guys doing
somebody yesterday in the comments uh
asked me to make a video about
shirk and obviously being the cardinal
sin the cardinal
the worst sin in islam worse than
anything else
why is it conceived as such how can we
justify
that which is loosely the association of
partners with god but
encompasses a lot more than this why is
this the worst thing
you could possibly do as a human being
so in this very short exposition and
obviously we are going to insha allah
like
talk about this more at length um
in in terms of in learning environments
obviously this is more casual
but some people will not be able to
just sit there for 20 or 30 minutes and
listen to lectures so i'm going to try
and abbreviate this
to less than 10 minutes and now that's a
very difficult thing to do
but shirk is loosely associating so
associating partners with god
which could be to make level okay
anything of the creation with god
the ultimate and the absolute how you
doing you're right
okay that's probably a good thing
it's just drunk i see that's all right
don't worry about it
i'll see you later yeah yeah
yes anyway
i guess obviously they want to sing to
the man
this is something normal uh natural this
is part of the
disposition to see someone like me uh
that you want to sing to the man to the
champ
uh this is fine this is uh normal
behavior i want a kid anyway um
so going back to the point associates of
making level
anything with god now either to put god
on the same level as anything
anything at the same level of god in any
of his attributes
in any of the worship that is owed to
god that you give it to other in god
any of his names okay anything like that
in the fact that of his lordship the
fact that he
grants um sustenance and development
to not only the universe but everything
around us to attribute anything
of those categories to anything other
than god
is to commit the cardinal sin of shirk
the cardinal sin okay sorry it's shaky
but i saw the faith so those who believe
in shook it's unstable and shaky you see
so we have to fix that uh or is to to
to bring god to the level of anything in
creation
and that could be in any of the three
ways aforementioned
okay so for example to to attribute
humanness to god to attribute weakness
to god to attribute
uh forgetfulness to god in any real
sense
uh to attribute any of the deficiencies
which uh color and categorize human
beings
and creatures in this world to
categorize god in any such way would be
to commit shirk
now why is that the worst thing the
quran states
unequivocally and unambiguously
that god does not accept that shirk is
done with him
but he actually he accepts anything else
to whomever he wants
why is there such a harsh penalty why
should such a bad thing
in contra distinction with anything else
even
the cabaret and we are talking here
about the shirk which
necessitates that someone really is
leaving islam
for all intents and purposes unless they
and in some cases they won't have an
excuse
do have an excuse so for example someone
sleep walking
okay because we don't want to take these
abstractions and start imposing them on
people
someone sleepwalking or someone is
they're you know
completely ignorant just came into islam
there may be some level of
excuse giving that we can give but
generally speaking in abstraction if
anyone does
these things they are stricken from the
islamic paradigm they are
beyond the pale of islam you see
so this is seen as the most cardinal sin
known
to man why so i want to present to you
guys the value
attribution argument okay the
the argument from divine value i call it
that
i've dubbed it as such what is the
argument from divine
value it's a very simple argument
which says that the more
the higher the attributes are of the one
that you are transgressing against
okay and that the more they are the more
of a sin or a crime of an immorality
that someone commits by doing by
committing such transgression
now i'll give this to you in a very
simple format
going into the car part um which is good
uh i say to you now for example if
someone were to say
if i cut a baby into two pieces okay
and i cut a tree into two pieces of
which
two pieces which of the two is a
worse thing to do on materialistic
atheism
uh you really don't really have an
answer because there's no intrinsic
value in either of the two
but if you said well actually the
intrinsic value will belong
in the attributes the two entities
um which inhere in the two
entities or which the two entities
um you could say the two entities have
okay the attributes that they can be
described with
then obviously we'll say the cutting of
the baby into two pieces
is more transgressive unethical and
immoral
than the cutting the tree into two
pieces
so this is an argument from attributes
okay now if we say well
if that is the case all right if that is
the case
then transgressing against
god is even worse you see because god
has got unlimited attributes
give me the ticket please thank you very
much where's the ticket
give me the ticket good good good now as
i was saying
so if it's to do with attributes the
situation is to do with attributes you
see
right now god has unlimited attributes
so transgressing against one with
unlimited attributes
is misappropriate or inappropriate i
should say
right which is of the highest level and
as such it should be punished at the
highest level
and someone says well you actually
believe in a hell fire
which burns people eternally yes
we absolutely believe in such hellfire
how can you justify someone will say a
hell fire that will
kulaman
every time that their skin is peeled off
we give them new skin that they may
taste the punishment the quran states
how can you justify you know such a
punishment to people
say for instance these people right may
have been worshipping god for 60 years
or sorry doing with god for 60
years
abdullah and lucy gave me a beautiful
answer which i continue to use and i
think it's a very fantastic
way of breaking this down the answer is
well look
if someone stabs someone to death that
takes a minute doesn't it all second
maybe
even two seconds three seconds now
you're not always going to go to the
court and say well
this person deserves to go to to prison
for two seconds
because the severity and the gravity of
the crime is such that it needs to be
punished for a longer period of time
despite the fact that it was done for
shorter period of time the gravity of
therefore is unparalleled in terms of
any comparative
any comparisons that anything else can
be made with it now
in conclusion it's not about shirk it's
about now identifying what share kids
because some people are quick to say
that shirk
that's kofora that's we really have to
assess
if these things are actually shirk or
not like we have a scandal
of a preacher abdul rahman hassan
who has studied islam for a long time
and he was saying
a minor form of shirk is sorry a man of
form of kufr
which is another category is if you play
football because it's
ruling with what other that allah has
revealed this is a scandal scandalous
in my opinion because it's just it's
making a mockery out of um
the religion of islam well i shouldn't
say monkey make a mockery but
it's mischaracterizing it it's
distorting the hierarchy in the religion
of islam
it's don't be afraid of people saying
this is shuriken this is kufar
to blackmail you into certain belief
systems or opinions
many people in this ummah of religion of
islam will use the terms
to blackmail people into action it's
we know what should is now in theory
okay now
in application that requires um kind of
thinking
applied knowledge okay is this shirk is
this not shirk
so what i want to say to everyone right
now is uh this is the
very basic skeletal model of what shirk
is and i'm going to try and stick to
what i said about it being under 10
minutes
it's a very very basic uh thing of what
shirk is we said is associating partners
with god giving any of the rights which
belong to god to other than god or any
of the rights that belong to the human
being
or elevating the human being to the
level of god this is shirk
now there are many actions you can do
that through giving the worship the
rights of worship
for of god to other than god you can do
that by doing tassuya or equaling or
leveling god
with other than god in either his names
and attributes in his sustaining power
and of course in uh
in his oneness and other things as well
so hopefully that makes sense
uh oh and so we said worship
okay this is what is referred to like
the sustenance and so on
which is the names and attributes of god
any leveling
when it relates to those three
categories in particular is seen
as shirk is seen as polytheism which is
the cardinal sin of islam
and there is a punishment waiting the
people
who intentionally do that uh because we
are born
believing and worship believing in the
the oneness of god to do that is to
distort one's natural
predisposition and to deny one's own
self